hi
hi this is steve
kaufman here i haven't done these for a
while so i thought i would talk a little
bit about language again
i'm going to speak in english and then i
might just cover some of the same ground
in maybe in
a couple of other languages in
subsequent uh
videos here
uh i was doing some research on the web
and uh i came across the fact that uh
mcgraw-hill
has just had their
tabe t-a-b-e
testing
format for
esl or english
approved by the
u.s department of education national
reporting service and so forth and so on
and so i clicked through some of the
links that were there and i came to
mcgraw-hill site and i see that
that they have that there are first of
all there are six levels uh in
tave
you know beginner low beginner high
beginner whatever there's very different
various different ways you can
call these levels but it's not uncommon
to divide
proficiency levels uh in in a language
into six levels the european
framework does that
um in canada we have a very complicated
thing called the 12 benchmarks and there
it's 12 levels but
whatever
but if you go to the mcgraw-hill website
you find that they are selling
uh books and cds for each of these
levels
eighty dollars or so for a book with cd
um
i know when i was in japan
in bookstores there that
sell books related to learning english
half the books that are on sale relate
to a test of some kind more than half
so testing is a huge part
of the whole language learning language
teaching industry
i i have no idea how much money is
involved but i'm sure it's in the
billions of dollars
i can just imagine how much time is
spent developing these tests
i am sure that the people who develop
the tests include all kinds of academic
and government officials so that they'll
have an inside track
on getting their tests
recognized and approved
there's so many different tests there's
toll and toefl and toeic and ielts and
now this tabe and others
more or less all duplicating each other
and i i i kind of have this feeling i've
spoken about testing before but
it to me it's all a colossal waste of
money
um
speaking is so natural it's such a
natural activity yes you have to have
tests for engineers you need all kinds
of certification if someone's going to
build a bridge
or or design a bridge or design a
building and there are
very clear you know objective standards
of in terms of the
the strength and the durability and the
flexibility and all these things that
can be accurately measured that are
physical properties of structures
and you have to have someone designing
a structure that is familiar with how
materials
function and their properties and so
forth and so on but speaking is just
communicating that's all we're trying to
do
there is no um
hey there's no danger the house is not
gonna fall down
uh there is no real
uh objective measurable uh some people
make grammar mistakes but communicate
very well some people might score very
highly on a grammar test and can't
communicate
uh some people require only a limited
amount of of communication ability some
jobs or situations require much more
furthermore you know what are you
measuring uh if a person is
is being tested based on his or her
ability to communicate because they're
about to be put into a situation where
they have to communicate
well
if you test them two months later after
they've been put in that situation they
will have already improved a great deal
and i know myself when i speak a
language sometimes i get things wrong
sometimes i get them right sometimes i
do better sometimes i do worse
um
i mean really
we add up all the time and money that's
put into developing these tests
administering these tests studying for
these tests
going to schools where you learn how to
do well on these tests
if you take that money and said all
right
what are we what do we want to know can
this person communicate well let's just
sit down and talk to them
let's we can talk over skype
via
the the webcam we can even have the
person send in
a five-minute discussion like i'm doing
right now in english send one in and the
language that you claim to speak
uh i i mean the cost of that is far far
less
and nor is it obvious that someone who's
tested and of course we test all the
time we test we test in schools we test
in grade five in grade six in grade
seven and the vast majority of kids
studying languages end up not speaking
the language so i i think that the the
effort and money that's put into testing
is
is just one aspect of the language
instruction
industry
that is
you know
spectacularly counterproductive
and
i don't know what the solution is i
guess the system is structured in such a
way that that's that's just what happens
and the experts say we need this and so
we do it
yeah
but i think all the people that were
behind the subprime
uh
lending fiasco in the united states
those were all experts too and they
built up this tremendous house of cards
that came crashing down
somewhere
hopefully common sense has to prevail
i mean i am quite fluent in japanese i
have never taken a test in japanese and
i have no desire to take a test in
japanese and
yes french i had tests at school but
when i really improved my french was
when i went to university in france and
i had to improve it in a hurry and then
my tests were not on the french language
per se but i had tests on the subjects
that i was writing about and i speak 10
languages now i had i had to write a
test in chinese but i would have learned
it without the test i i was motivated by
things that interested me and my
interest in the language now people are
going to say not everyone's interested
and therefore you have to test those
people who aren't interested
i say if you didn't get them to study
for the test if you tried to make it
more interesting for them a larger
number of people would end up able to
communicate in the language and the
biggest example of that is japan where
two million people a year write the
toeic test they have terrible scores on
average those people in japan want to
learn english do those people who just
want to pass the toy test never end up
being able to communicate very well so
i'm going to stop it there and then i'm
going to perhaps
put up another one where i will say
another one of these but i will say the
same thing
in japanese or similar things bye for